bonjour à toutes et à tous dans cette
nouvelle année accompagné de notre
président du conseil départemental des
jeunes Sarah fiamm je veux vous adresser
mes meilleurs vœux de bonheur de santé
et de confiance la confiance est le
moteur de l'attraction l'espion
départemental représente avec nos 266
communes la proximité et vous accompagne
au quotidien dans la Vienne nous
apportons la preuve avec de la confiance
du bon sens et de la volonté il est
possible d'avancer ensemble
c'est aussi celle qui est fait au
conseil départemental des jeunes avec
tous les collégiens autour de moi nous
travaillons pendant ce mandat sur des
actions visant à encourager notre
jeunesse à s'investir à s'engager à
faire des propositions en donnant la
parole au jeune le département investi
pour l'avenir toute l'équipe de du
conseil départemental et celle du
conseil des jeunes autour de Sarah qui
m'accompagne ainsi que tous les agents
de notre collectivité sont mobilisés à
mes côtés en 2022 nous continuerons à
répondre à vos besoins parce que les
solidarités sont notre priorité en 2022
nous confort tronc notre belle dynamique
d'investissement pour un territoire
toujours plus attractif tourné vers
l'innovation c'est la volonté de
l'ensemble de notre majorité en 2022
vous verrez aussi l'éclosion de grands
projets l'Arena Futuroscope le collège
Joséphine Baker à Vouneuil-sous-Biard le
château de Monts-sur-Guesnes
ces projets sont source de dynamisme et
d'attractivité pour la Vienne
en 2022 nous continuerons à porter haut
et fort nos valeurs proximité solidarité
bon sens nidron encore notre action je
crois en notre département je crois en
notre projet solidaire et ambitieux pour
la Vienne je crois en notre capacité
collective à nous projeter avec
confiance vers l'avenir au nom de toute
l'assemblée départementale nous vous
souhaitons à toutes et à tous une belle
et heureuse année 2022
[Musique]